hey guys i'm david dobrik and today i'm
reading thirst tweets i was told these
are real these are hundred percent real
okay the way david dobrik eats makes me
horny you know what I want to say screw
you to my parents for this because they
would always make fun of me for how I
eat look at this I turn people on I
don't know I just cram a bunch of food
into my mouth which I guess some people
find it amusing
and I appreciate that I will continue
eating for you punch me in my Buzzi
that's a [ __ ] I will I will knock the
bat of your Buzzi I will ping
what is the [ __ ] I mean I I think I
know what it is do me of a mannequin I
can perform all these stunts on david
dobrik is one thick bit let me see that
Dave OC what's a Dave receipt I
appreciate it thank you I don't I don't
really know what this one I kind of knew
what bus he was but Dave OC is confusing
I'm assuming that's like my like a
friendly way of saying penis right
genitals nope you guys know what it is
why are you looking at me like I'm an
idiot
yeah this is an actual work oh my
[ __ ] oh I'll show you my Dave Lisi I
don't want these times can I lick your
big toe yeah I never understood the
fascination with people's toes actually
no what like at one point I probably had
a foot fetish you can me I hate when
people sexualized celebrities also me I
would literally david dobrik like sit on
my face
I'm not getting turned on I take all
these to the bathroom who has the most
beautiful legs david dobrik I really
appreciate that um I used to play tennis
and I still really short shorts so it's
nice to know that every time people were
looking at me play that they were
enjoying what they were seeing I just
want everyone to know that I'm
officially a hole for david dobrik well
this one's good cuz it's so gross
it's so dehumanizing to say that I'm a
hole I'll treat you like my purse I'll
keep my camera in there
filming I would let david dobrik spit
down my throat can we find this person
and I will spit down their throat right
now I want david dobrik to shove his
Tesla blowtorch in my hole and release
me from the inside out I should come to
you guys for more video ideas this is
great
I want david dobrik to destroy my
insides now I don't know if they want me
to feed them at Carolina Reaper pepper
or if they want me to have sex with them
DME serious inquiries only when I'm
horny I have a hard time deciding if I
want to watch a porn hub or david dobrik
vlogs I feel like I'd rather watch
pornhub trying to imagine how my videos
would help you masturbate but then again
I've masturbated to find it yes look I
don't understand it either but I love
david dobrik he radiates BGE and that's
all be these big dick energy I am going
to individual EDM all of us it's last
one david dobrik if you see this just
know i want to use your as a face mask
well if you see this you'll be happy to
hear we're coming out with new merch the
work you can use Michael as a face mask
show me you yes what oh this one's long
we got a new one they weren't gonna show
me this one cuz it's too explicit I've
seen this person tweet I haven't I
haven't read it but I've seen this
person's tweets they're looking insane
david dobrik please let me suck look
I've seen this exact tweet David Oberg
please let me suck the [ __ ] out of your
tip drop I drop like a hamster rat him
into my throat it's so hard that I throw
up and forced me to lick the vomit off
your balls me in front of a church spit
in my mouth and not in me then lick it
out of me
show me how you squirt I've seen this
one and I want to favorite it but I know
it's a bad look but I can appreciate you
you work hard and you're gonna get
places thanks for having me must be what
you guys are [ __ ] sick